ROB PIKE: Hi, everyone.
Wow.
Voice is always so big.
Thanks for coming.
I'm going to be talking today
about Go concurrency patterns.
My name is Rob Pike, and I work
on the Go team at Google.
First of all, let me give
us a little background.
When Go came out in November of
2009, a lot of people were
immediately fascinated by the
features of Go that provided
concurrency, and wanted
to play with
them and goof around.
But also, a lot of people had
questions about them.
And there's a question
about why
concurrency's even in the language.
What exactly do I mean
by concurrency?
What is the origin
of the ideas?
And what is it all useful for?
And today I'm going to talk
about all those things, but
I'm mostly going to talk about
how you use the features.
But I need to give you
a little background.
So if you look around in the
world at large, what you see
is a lot of independently
executing things.
You see people in the audience
doing their own thing,
tweeting while I'm talking
and stuff like that.
There's people outside,
there's cars going by.
All those things are independent
agents, if you
will, inside the world.
And if you think about writing
a computer program, if you
want to simulate or interact
with that environment, a
single sequential execution is
not a very good approach.
And so concurrency is really a
way of writing or structuring
your program to deal with
the real world.
And what I mean by concurrency,
we define as the
composition of independently
executing computations.
And I want to stress that
concurrency is a way of
structuring software.
It's a way of thinking about how
to write clean code that
can interact with the real
world, and maybe simulate the
real world or behave as an agent
inside the real world,
and be a good actor in
that environment.
Concurrency is really
not parallelism.
Although a lot of people got
confused by that, and I think
when Go first launched, a lot
of people thought Go was a
parallel language.
It's not really a parallel
language.
It's a concurrent one.
And one to realize the
difference is to imagine--
if you have a concurrent piece
of code that you've written
that uses the concurrency
features of Go or any other
concurrent language, but you
only run it on a single
processor, then it's certainly
not a parallel program,
because it's not executing
anything in parallel.
But it can still have concurrent
structure.
And even on a single processor,
that could be a
useful way to model the
way this stuff works.
Now I actually give a talk at
the beginning of the year at a
Heroku conference, which you can
find online, where I talk
about in great detail about what
the difference is between
concurrency and parallelism.
I don't want to spend too
much time on it today.
But I want to stress that I'm
talking about concurrency
here, not parallelism.
And just to stress this,
concurrency is a model for
software construction.
And the reason it's valuable is
that to interact with the
real world, you have to figure
out how to write your software
to do that.
And concurrency and features
provided by Go, but also in
other languages, are
easy to understand.
They're easy to use.
They're easy to reason about--
which is really important,
because you don't need to be
an expert to use them.
You can use the concurrency
features of Go without
understanding all of the
minutiae of memory barriers
and threads and condition
variables and all the other
stuff that people often think
of as the standard way to
program parallel or concurrent
applications.
It's just not true.
You can work at a much higher
level and make it a lot easier
for yourself.
And in fact, a lot of people
have used Go to write
concurrent programs who've
never done concurrent
programming before, and they
find it's actually
quite easy to do.
Now to many people, as I said,
when Go came out, the
concurrency stuff seems kind
of new and intriguing.
It's not actually totally
original.
In fact, there's a very long
history of concurrent ideas
and programming languages that
leads towards Go, and I've
listed some of them here.
The most important one is
a seminal paper, which I
actually recommend every
computer programmer in the
world should read, is by Tony
Hoare, in 1978, called
"Communicating Sequential
Processes." And that is the
fundamental paper.
All the real ideas
are in there.
And all these other languages
build on the ideas from that
paper to construct real
programming environments.
Probably the most original
language that came out of this
was this thing called Occam,
which was the programming
language for the transputer.
It came out in the early '80s.
You've mostly probably
heard of Erlang.
And there's another branch that
I had a role in, with
languages like Newsqueak
and Limbo.
There's also Concurrent ML, done
by John Reppy, which is
actually a lovely language.
It's a functional language,
but it's concurrent.
It's kind of amazing, but it's
another level of intellectual
depth that some programmers
aren't as comfortable with.
But it is a beautiful
language.
Go is on the branch of the
Newsqueak-Limbo-Alef sequence.
And the thing that distinguishes
them from most
of these others is that it has
the idea of a channel as a
first-class value.
In the original Hoare CSP, you
communicated directly with a
process by name, and that's
essentially the way Erlang
still works today.
But in Go, instead you don't
talk to a process.
You talk to a channel, and the
other end of that channel is
some other thing that could be
reading the values that you're
sending to it.
And one way to understand that
distinction is that the Erlang
original CSP idea is a little
bit like writing to a file by
name, whereas in Go, the channel
idea is more like
writing to a file descriptor.
And the level of indirection
that it provides is actually
kind of important to a lot
of things that get done.
But I want to stress that
one model isn't
better than the other.
They're actually formally
equivalent.
You can write one form in
terms of the other.
But Go definitely is
about channels.
So enough of this sort of
theoretical nonsense.
Let's actually show some code.
Now one of the problems with
illustrating concurrent
programming is that the ideas
tend to be subtle if you've
never seen them before.
And people tend to write
complicated examples to
demonstrate them.
And I don't want to do that.
So instead, I'm going to make
all of my code today be around
really boring things.
So these are going to be really
boring programs, but
they're going to use concurrency
to make the boring
a little less interesting.
And this gives it a focus on
the concurrency rather than
the boring elements that
are actually being made
concurrent.
So here's a particularly
boring program.
All it does is print very
slowly, once per
second, la la la.
Now I'd like to stress,
actually, what's going on here
is that every time I hit the run
button here-- this is an
HTMI5 presentation--
it compiles the binary out of
the HTML, runs it, and pops up
this window talking with a web
socket back to the browser.
And it's all done in Go.
By doing it this way, you get
to see the actual code
running, and you also trust that
what's going on here is
really what I'm showing you.
It's really important for the
concurrency because timing
things come in.
So let's make this program a
little less boring by putting
in a random sleeping interval so
that they run a little less
deterministically, so there's a
little randomness in there.
OK.
Pretty boring program, right?
You still with me?
All right.
Now let's run this thing.
So it's pretty easy.
Here's the whole program except
for some boilerplate at
the top, and there's the whole
program running out of the
thing, and la la la.
OK.
Extremely boring.
Good.
Now boring things are things
you want to ignore.
So let's ignore that.
To do that, we run the boring
function as a goroutine.
I"ll talk a little bit more
about goroutines in a minute.
But for now, just think of a
goroutine as being analogous
to launching a shell command
with an ampersand on the end
of the line.
It says, run this function
in the background.
I don't care about it.
I'm just going to keep
executing directly.
So let's run this.
Something went wrong.
That's not actually a bug.
This is actually what Go does.
What happened down here is
that we launched this
goroutine, and then main
immediately returned because
we didn't have to wait.
But the way it Go is defined,
when main returns, the program
actually exits.
And so this is sort of a
feature of Go that's
deliberate.
When main returns, the
program goes away.
But it also confuses
people, at first.
So I put it in the very
first example.
So when you run the program, it
launches the goroutine, but
the program returns
and we're done.
So let's make that a little
more interesting by doing
something after we launch
the goroutine.
So here we launch it, and now
we print a couple of things
out, wait for a while,
and then exit.
So now you can see that, in
fact, we are running both the
boring function and the main
function concurrently.
Right?
Very, very simple.
So what are these goroutines?
Well, it's an independently
executing function.
You can think of, when you run
a function, normally you wait
for the function to complete,
and you get the answer back.
The goroutine says, run the
function, but I don't want to
wait for the answer
to come back.
Just go and execute
independently of me.
So this is the sort of
fundamental idea of composing.
So in Go, concurrency is the
composition of independently
executing goroutines.
It's got its own stack.
And the stack actually grows
and shrinks as required.
So unlike some threading
libraries, where you have to
say how big the stack is, it's
never an issue in Go.
You don't have to say how
big the stack is.
It will be made as big as it
needs to be, and if the stack
grows, the system will
take care of the
stack growth for you.
And they start out very small.
So it's very cheap and practical
to have thousands or
even tens of thousands of
goroutines running.
And I'll show you an example,
later, where we have
way more than that.
And we've even seen large jobs
running in production with
millions of them.
So they're very, very
cheap things.
They're not threads.
However, for the point of view
of understanding them, it's
not misleading to think of a
goroutine as just an extremely
cheap thread.
Because that's really, in
effect, what they are.
What happens in the runtime is
goroutines are multiplexed
onto threads that are created
as needed in order to make
sure no goroutine ever blocks.
So you just launch the
goroutines, and you don't have
to think about it.
And that's kind of the point.
Now our example that we ran
before, where we started the
goroutine, printed a bit,
and then exited, that
was actually a cheat.
Because the goroutines were
independently executing, but
they were not communicating or
synchronizing their behavior
in any way.
I just started this guy, this
program talked, and the other
one kept running, which isn't
a very helpful example.
And so to do a proper concurrent
program, you need
to be able to communicate
among the
goroutines inside it.
And to do that, there is a
concept of a channel in Go.
And as I mentioned earlier,
channels are sort of a
fundamental concept in Go.
And they're first-class values,
and they're really
interesting.
And we'll use them to do
some interesting stuff.
But the basics are very
straightforward.
The first block there shows
you how to declare and
initialize a channel.
So var c chan int says declare
a variable called c that has
type channel of integer.
And channels are types, so the
values that go on the channels
have a static type, in
this case, int or
integer, default integer.
And then to create a channel,
you actually have to
initialize it by saying
make of chan int.
And in Go syntax, you typically
use the := notation.
So those two lines above are
equivalent to this c
:= make chan int.
And you tend to see that kind
of code all the time.
When you want to send a value
on a channel, you use the
left-pointing arrow operator.
And so this sends the value
1 on the channel.
And then to receive it, you
put the arrow on the other
side of the c, and now the
value comes out of the
channel, so that's a
receive operation.
So if one goroutine says c
gets 1, then the other
goroutine says, receive from
c and store the value.
That sends this 1 into the
channel and then out again
into the variable.
And the way to think about the
mnemonic here is that the
arrow points in the direction
in which the channel is
sending data.
So here, the 1 is pointing
into the channel.
Here the arrow's pointing out of
the channel and delivering
it to the value.
So let's use the channel
to do something.
Let's make this program we have
a little more honest.
So here's our main function.
And now, this time in a loop,
we actually say printf, you
say some value, and here is that
receive on the channel,
which we made up here.
And then in the boring function,
we just loop
forever, sending a printed
message to the channel.
So if we run this, you can see
the program running, and then
for five times, it says that.
So this is honest, right?
This main and the boring
function are independently
executing, but they're
also communicating
in the strong sense.
So there's a point about what's
going on here, which
is, obviously when you read from
a channel, you have to
wait for there to be
a value there.
It's a blocking operation.
But also when you
send to a value,
it's a blocking operation.
When you send a value on a
channel, the channel blocks
until somebody's ready
to receive it.
And so as a result, if the two
goroutines are executing, and
this one's sending, and this
one's receiving, whatever
they're doing, when they finally
reach the point where
the send and receive are
happening, we know that's like
a lockstep position.
Those two goroutines are at
that communication point--
the send on this side and the
receive on this side.
So it's also a synchronization
operation as well as a send
and receive operation.
And channels thus
communicate and
synchronize in a single operation.
And that's a pretty
fundamental idea.
Now for those experts in the
room who know about buffered
channels in Go-- which exist--
you can create a
channel with a buffer.
And buffered channels have the
property that they don't
synchronize when you send,
because you can just drop a
value in the buffer
and keep going.
So they have different
properties.
And they're kind of subtle.
They're very useful for certain
problems, but you
don't need them.
And we're not going to use them
at all in our examples
today, because I don't want
to complicate life
by explaining them.
But the thing about buffered
channels is they're much more
like mailboxes in Erlang, so
I thought it was worth
mentioning.
OK so given this idea of
communication coupled with
synchronization that Go's
channels provide, the Go
approach to concurrent software
can be characterized
as, don't communicate
by sharing memory.
Share memory by communicating.
In other words, you don't have
some blob of memory and then
put locks and mutexes and
condition variables around it
to protect it from
parallel access.
Instead, you actually use the
channel to pass the data back
and forth between the goroutines
and make your
concurrent program
operate that way.
So based on those principles,
we can now start to do some,
what I call, concurrency
"patterns." And I put it in
quotes because I don't want you
to think of these as being
like object-oriented patterns.
They're just very simple,
little, tiny examples that do
interesting things.
So the first and probably most
important concurrency pattern
is what I call a generator,
which is a function that
returns a channel.
So all of these examples for the
next few slides are going
to be variants of the things I
showed you before, but I'm
going to do them in
different ways.
So in this case, what we do is
we take our boring function,
and we give it a return value.
We say that this boring function
is going to return a
channel of string, and this
less-than means that the
return value is a channel that
you can only receive from
because the main function is
only going to use it as a
received value.
So in this case, in the main
function, we call the boring
function, and it returns
the channel.
And then this is the
same as before.
We just receive and print the
values that come out.
And in the boring function,
instead of sort of looping
forever, with the goroutine
being launched in main, we
actually launch the goroutine
inside the
boring function itself.
You can see here,
it says go func.
This is a function literal.
So this is the loop that we had
before, but it's wrapped
inside an anonymous function
literal and then launched with
a Go keyword at the top.
And so this starts the
computation and then returns
back to the caller the channel
with which to communicate to
that process that's running,
that goroutine.
And so from the outside, this
just looks like a function
whose invocation returns a
channel, and internally, it
actually starts a computation
running concurrently.
So let's run that.
This will behave exactly the
same way, but now we've got a
much nicer pattern for
constructing this service.
And in fact, this is very much
like having a service.
We could use multiple instances
of this boring
function, give them different
names, and we'd have different
services, each of which
are talking to us.
So here's a simple example where
we actually launch the
boring function twice, and then
in the loop, just print a
value from Joe and
a value from Ann.
And it's exactly the same boring
function as previously.
We're just using it in
a different way.
So you can see, you get a 0 from
Joe and Ann, a 1 from Joe
and Ann, a 2 from Joe
and Ann, and so on.
Now inside here, we're reading
a value from Joe and
a value from Anne.
And because of the
synchronization nature of the
channels, the two guys are
taking turns, not only in
printing the values out, but
also in executing them.
Because if Ann is ready to send
a value but Joe hasn't
done that yet, Ann will still be
blocked, waiting to deliver
the value to main.
Well, that's a little annoying
because maybe Ann is more
talkative than Joe and doesn't
want to wait around.
So we can get around that by
writing a fan-in function or a
multiplexer.
And to do that--
here's this fan-in function--
we actually stitch the two guys
together with the fan-in
function and construct a single
channel, from which we
can receive from both of them.
And the way to think of it is
a little bit like this.
Here's Joe, and here's Ann,
and they're both talking.
And then the fan-in function
here is taking values from Joe
and values from Ann and just
forwarding them on to the
output of the fan-in function.
Right?
And to do that, again, it's
using the generator pattern.
The fan-in function is
itself a function
that returns a channel.
It takes two channels as input,
returns another channel
as its return value.
And what we do is, again, make
the channel and return it.
But internally, we launch two
independent goroutines, one
copying the output from input1
to the channel, and the other
one copying the data from
input2 to the channel.
So when we call fanIn of boring
Joe and boring Ann,
remember, they return
channels.
They become the arguments to the
fan-in function, and then
we launch two more goroutines
to copy the data.
And so we run this guy.
Ann and Joe are now completely
independent.
And you can see, when it runs,
that they run in not
necessarily sequential order.
Because there's Joe gives three
communications in a row,
there, before Ann had anything
else to say.
OK?
So that decouples the execution
of those guys.
So even though it's all
synchronous, they can
independently execute.
So what if, for some reason, we
actually don't want that?
We wanted to have them be
totally lockstep and
synchronous.
Well to do that, remember I
said these channels are
first-class values in Go.
That means that we can pass
a channel on a channel.
And so we can send inside a
channel another channel to be
used for the answer
to come back.
To do this, what we do is we
construct a message structure
that includes the message that
we want to print, and we
include inside there another
channel that is what we call a
wait channel.
And that's like a signaler.
And the guy will block on the
wait channel until the person
says, OK, I want you
to go ahead.
So let's see how that works.
So here's our main loop--
again, just five times
around the loop.
We receive a message from the
first person and send it--
this is, again, the fan-in
functions on the
other side of this.
Receive another one and print
that, and then wait them out.
Now notice that this is
message1 and message2.
They have channels inside them
that are the guys that are
going to be used to
do the sequencing.
So inside the boring functions,
now, we have this
wait-for-it channel, and then
everybody blocks, waiting for
a signal to advance.
So when we run it now, you can
see they're back in lockstep,
because even though the timing
is random, the sequencing
here, with message1 wait and
message2 wait, means that the
independently executing guys
are waiting on different
channels for the signal
to advance.
Now that's all fairly simple
and kind of silly.
We can make it a little more
interesting by using the next
part of concurrency in Go, which
is the select statement.
And the select statement is a
control structure, somewhat
like a switch, that lets you
control the behavior of your
program based on what
communications are able to
proceed at any moment.
And in fact, the select
statement is really sort of a
key part of why concurrency is
built into Go as features of
the language, rather than
just a library.
It's hard to control structures
that depend on libraries.
It's much easier this way.
So here's how a select
statement works.
It looks kind of complicated.
There's a lot of text
on this slide.
But it's really pretty simple.
A select statement looks
like a switch.
It's got a bunch of cases.
And each case, instead of
being an expression, is
actually a communication.
So you can see, there's
a receive, a
receive, and a send.
And what happens in this select
statement is when you
come to the top of the select,
it evaluates all of the
channels that could be used for
communication inside the
cases, and then it blocks
until one of
them is ready to run.
And once one is available to
run, that case executes, and
the whole select goes on.
So it's much like a regular
switch statement, except it
blocks until a communication
can proceed.
And there's a default that you
can put inside a select.
If there's no default, then the
select will block forever
until the channel can proceed.
If there is a default, what
it means is, if nobody can
proceed right away, then just
execute the default.
And this gives you way to do
non-blocking communication.
We're not going to depend on
that, but I just wanted to
make sure you knew
it was there.
So it's really pretty simple.
The only other sort of wrinkle
is that sometimes multiple
channels are available
at the same time.
When that happens, the select
statement chooses one
pseudo-randomly.
So you can't depend on the
order in which the
communications will proceed.
Those of you who know Dijkstra's
guarded commands
will recognize the
pattern there.
It's very much like the guarded
if statement inside
Dijkstra's commands.
So here's our fan-in function.
Same functionality, but now
written using select.
So here's our old guy.
This is exactly the function
we had before, you can see.
And here's the new one using
the select statement.
If I go back and forth, you can
see the difference is, the
original guy started two
goroutines, one for each input
channel to be copied
to the output.
The new guy starts a single
goroutine because it's still
got that generator pattern.
But instead of two copy loops,
it runs one copy loop, and it
selects which of the two is
ready and passes the data on
appropriately.
So this has exactly the same
behavior as the other one,
except that we're only launching
one goroutine inside
the fan-in function.
Same idea, different
implementation.
Now we can use selects
to do all kinds
of interesting things.
One of the most important is
we can use it to time out a
communication.
So if you're talking to somebody
who's very boring,
chances are you don't want to
wait very long for them to get
around to saying something.
So in this case, we can simulate
that with a call to a
function in the library
called time.After.
And here, this select statement
says either we can
get a message from Joe, or a
second's gone by, and he
hasn't said anything,
in which case, we'll
just get out of here.
So time.After is a function
inside the standard library
that returns a channel that will
deliver a value after the
specified interval.
So in this case, either we get
a message, or a second goes
by, and we don't get a message,
and then we finish.
So if we run it, you can see,
Joe goes for a while.
And then he takes too long to
say something, and so we exit.
OK?
I think it always does this.
I think I forgot to seed it.
It's always saying
the same thing.
All right.
But you see the idea.
We just keep going around this
loop until the timeout fires.
Now you can do that
another way.
We might decide, instead of
having a conversation where
each message is at most one
second, we might just want a
total time elapsed.
And to do that, we can use the
time.After channel more
directly by just saving it
inside a timeout channel and
using it inside the
select statement.
So in this case, this loop, this
entire loop will time out
after five seconds.
So it doesn't matter how many
times Joe says anything.
After five seconds,
we're out there.
Boom.
OK?
So that times out
the whole loop.
The difference, here, is we're
timing out each message.
Here, we're timing out the
whole conversation.
Now another thing you can do
with a select is instead of
using a timeout, you could
actually deterministically
say, OK, I'm done.
Stop now.
So here's our inner loop again,
the select inside the
inner loop.
There's the send
on the message.
But we actually have a second
case which is a quit channel.
And what we do there is in the
main function, we create some
quit channel.
In this case, it doesn't
matter what type it is.
I just picked bool.
And then after we've printed as
many times we want what he
has to say, we signal
him and say, OK.
I'm done.
And so at that point, this case
can proceed, because this
guy's not communicating and
will eventually stop.
So again, this is the same
thing as before.
But now after only two
executions, we
decide that's enough.
We tell him to quit.
And so the quit case executes
in the select, the function
returns, and the boring
conversation is over.
Now there's a problem with
that model, though.
Because in here, in this case,
what if after this function is
done, he needs to do something
inside here?
So he gets the message to stop,
but he might have some
cleanup functions to do.
Remember that when main returns
from a Go program, the
whole thing shuts down.
Maybe he's got to remove
some temporary files or
something like that.
We want to make sure that he's
finished before we really
exit, and so we need to do a
slightly more sophisticated
communication.
And it's very easy to do that.
We just turn around and say,
send me a message back when
you're done.
And so in this case, we say
"Bye!" But then Joe gets the
message on the quit statement,
does a cleanup, and then tells
you, OK, I'm done.
And this gives synchronization
for the two programs, to make
sure that they're both where
they want to be.
So in this case, you see we tell
him "Bye!" And then the
quit fires.
We do whatever cleanup
is required.
Then we respond.
But now we're telling him that
we're done for sure, and so
it's safe for him to exit.
And this is a round-trip
communication.
Now speaking of round-trips, we
can also make this crazy by
having a ridiculously long
sequence of these things, one
talking to another one.
So think of it like this.
You've got a whole bunch of
gophers who want to do a
Chinese Whispers game, although
I think Chinese
Whispers with megaphones
might sort of
make it a little weird.
But you see the idea, here.
This guy's sends a message
to him, sends a message--
forwards it, forwards
it, forwards it.
And the last guy receives the
message and prints it out.
Now I want to stress that
this is not a loop.
This is just going all the way
around the chain, back to the
answer here.
And to make it interesting--
this is the gopher here--
what he does is receive
from the left--
sorry, receive from the
right, because this
is where it's going.
Coming in from the right.
Sending to the left.
So you receive on the right.
And then we make it a channel
of integers, so I'm
going to add 1.
And the reason for that is, that
lets us count the number
of steps, so the distortion in
the Chinese Whispers game is
we add 1 to the value.
And I'm not going to
go through all the
details of this code.
This is actually sort of subtle,
and I don't want
explain it all.
But all it does is basically
construct this diagram using
channels to send the
answers along.
And then everybody's
waiting for the
first thing to be sent.
And so we launch the value into
the first channel and
then wait for it to come out
of the leftmost guy.
So it goes, vvvvt, around
the channel.
And for the sake of fun, I'm
going to run 100,000 gophers.
Now remember that I'm going to
compile the program, link it,
and then run it.
And it takes that long to do
100,000 goroutines and all the
communication.
[APPLAUSE]
ROB PIKE: Those are
some fast gophers.
OK.
Now this is obviously
a silly example, but
it's an honest one.
Because I really am creating all
those elements and doing
the full communication and
the whole shebang.
So you can think of goroutines
as being very, very
lightweight things.
They're even smaller
than gophers.
OK.
But so far, everything we've
been doing is very toy-like.
And I want to stress that Go
was designed for building
system software.
And I want to talk now about
how we use these ideas to
construct the kind of software
that we care about.
Now we did this at Google, and
so what we're going to do is
build a Google search engine.
Sort of.
It's still going to be a toy.
I can't develop a Google search
engine in less than
about a half an hour, and
I only have 15 minutes.
But we can start.
So think about what a
Google search does.
If you're going to the Google
web page and you run a search,
you get a bunch of
answers back.
And some might be web pages,
there could be videos, there
could be song clips, or weather
reports, or whatever.
There's a bunch of independently
executing back
ends that are looking at that
search for you and finding
results that are interesting.
And there might also be some
ads, so there's an ad system
running, too.
And so in parallel, you want
to send all of these things
out to the back ends and then
gather all the answers back
and deliver them.
How do we actually
structure that?
Well, let's fake
it, completely.
Let's construct a thing called
a fakeSearch, and all our
fakeSearch is going to do is
sleep for a while and then
return whatever the fake answer
is that it wants, which
is very uninteresting.
It says, here's your result.
But the point is that there's
multiple of them.
And it's actually a function.
So notice here, this search is
a function that takes a query
and returns a result.
So that's sort of a type
definition for what a search
actually does.
And we construct these functions
for a web, an image,
and a video service.
OK?
Very simple.
All they do is pause for a
while, and then print.
And they're set to wait for
up to 100 milliseconds.
So let's test it out.
So here--
this time I'm going to seed the
random number generator,
so the values are always
different.
And we start the timer, get the
results from the search,
and then print out
how long it took.
OK?
So if I run this guy, you can
see that was 168 milliseconds.
Now remember, each of these guys
could take up to about
100 milliseconds.
So we could see up to, like,
300 milliseconds, maybe.
There's 160.
There's 94, that was
a quick one.
213, that was a slow one.
So these are actually, you
know, running these guys.
OK.
Now let's make it an actual real
function that returns all
of the values back, right?
So here, we actually have this
Google function that takes a
query and queries all of the
back ends and gathers all of
the results together and returns
back a slice of the
results, which is--
think of it as just an
array of results.
So here we run this guy, and
you can see, there are the
three things, taking
a little longer to
gather all of the data.
OK.
Trivia, right?
The problem is that if you
think about it, this is
running one guy, waiting for
his answer to come back,
running another one, waiting for
running a third one, waiting for
his answer to come back.
Well, you know where
this is going.
Why don't we launch those
in goroutines?
So now for each of the back
ends, we independently launch
a goroutine to do the search,
and then-- this
is the fan-in pattern--
get the data back on
the same channel.
And then we can just print
them out as they arrive.
So they're going to come out of
order now, but we're going
to get all three of them back.
But they're running
concurrently, and actually in
parallel, in this case.
And so we don't have to wait
around nearly as long.
So there, we see,
76 milliseconds.
That's pretty quick.
88 milliseconds.
Now we're really only waiting
for the slowest, the single
slowest web search.
15 milliseconds.
There you go.
So that's pretty cool.
And notice that this is a
parallel program, now, with
multiple back ends running.
But we don't have any
mutexes or locks
or condition variables.
The model of Go's concurrency
is taking care of the
intricacy of setting up and
running this safely.
Now sometimes, servers
take a long time.
They can be really,
really slow.
So remember, we set these
up for 100 milliseconds.
Once in a while, an individual
search might take more than 80
milliseconds.
And let's say we don't want to
wait more than a total of 80
milliseconds for the
whole thing to run.
We want to use the timeout
pattern now.
So here's the fan-in pattern,
and here's the timeout for the
whole conversation.
We run this guy now, and
81 milliseconds.
That was pretty quick.
44 milliseconds.
You see, these are
fairly quick now.
They're typically 80
milliseconds or less, which is
what they should be, because
we never wait.
But if I run this
enough times--
there.
We timed out because, in
this case, two of the
queries took too long.
And so all we got back
was the web result.
We didn't get the other two.
And that's a kind
of nice idea.
We know that we're going to be
able to get you an answer
within 80 milliseconds.
However, timing out a
communication is kind of annoying.
What if the server really is
going to take a long time?
It's kind of a shame to
throw it on the floor.
So now we add replication.
So if we run three instances of
the service, say, or five,
one of them is likely
to come back
before the timeout expires.
If only one of them is having a
problem, the other ones can
all be efficient.
So how do we structure that?
Well, here's our familiar
pattern by now.
We actually write a function
called First that takes a
query and a set of replicas--
this is the Go notation for
a variadic function--
so we have a bunch of replicas
of a search that we're going
to do, for a single search.
Like, replicas of the web search
or replicas of the
image search.
And we make the channel
of results.
And then we launch the same
search multiple times and then
return the first one
that comes back.
See, all these guys are going
to talk on the channel, but
we're only going to return the
first one that we get.
And so this will give us the
first result from all those
back end guys.
So here's a simple use of it,
where we run two replicas.
And that time we got replica
2 in 30 milliseconds.
Replica 2, Replica 1 in 24.
So you can see, it's whichever
one comes back first.
There's five milliseconds.
And with that little tool, now,
we can build the next
piece, which is to stitch all
of this magic together.
So this is Google Search
3.0, full on.
It's got everything in it.
It has the fan-in function, it's
got the replicated back
end stuff, it's got a timeout
on everybody.
And so we should, with very,
very high probability now, get
all three of our web search
results back in less than 80
milliseconds.
So there's 40 milliseconds,
56 milliseconds.
You notice, they're
all three there.
There's no timeouts.
18, 39, 51.
And this is obviously
a toy example.
But you can see how we're using
the concurrency ideas in
Go to build, really, a fairly
sophisticated, parallel,
replicated, robust thing.
And that's kind of
the message.
Because it's very simple
to do that.
There's still none of that sort
of minutiae of memory
barriers and nonsense that
people who use threading
approaches are aware of.
And there's no callback, so this
is very different from
using, like, node.js, or
something like that.
That program is fairly
easy to understand.
More important, the individual
elements of the program are
all just straightforward
sequential code.
And we're composing their
independent execution to give
us the behavior of
the total server.
So to summarize what we just did
there, we started with a
very simple program that was
slow and consequential and
failure-sensitive, at least
we pretended it is.
And by using the concurrency
ideas in Go, we made that same
stuff run quickly, concurrently,
in a replicated
way, and with much
more robustness.
And this is sort
of the lesson.
This was actually why
the concurrency
features went into Go.
It's because it makes it easy
to go from this to this
without worrying about safety
issues and things like that.
It's just a very much more
straightforward approach to
constructing what I loosely
describe as server software.
There's all kinds
of party tricks.
This is barely, barely touching
the surface, and
there'll probably have to be a
talk again soon with a lot
more rich examples using
other features that I
haven't shown you today.
But there's lots of talks
on the web already, with
independent things about using
Go concurrency stuff to solve
some interesting problems.
There's a Chatroulette toy,
which Andrew talked about,
that has a fairly amazing little
inner loop in it that
you should probably check out.
A couple of years ago at I/O, I
talked about a dynamic load
balancer which uses channels
as first-class values to
construct some pretty
interesting stuff.
There's a legendary example
called the Concurrent Prime
Sieve, which is kind of
an amazing thing.
It was the first truly beautiful
concurrent program I
think I ever saw.
But it's completely dwarfed by
this work by Doug McIlroy,
who's my old boss at Bell Labs,
who wrote a concurrent
power series library using a
predecessor language to Go.
And it treats the coefficients
of a power series as values in
a channel, sequential
values in a channel.
And using some very simple
tricks, very much like what I
just showed you, it manages to
do some incredibly high-level
mathematics that is very, very
difficult to do any other way.
It's really rather beautiful.
So there's the links if you
want to check them out.
Now having just said how
wonderful all this is, I want
to throw out a word
of caution.
This stuff is fun.
It's really fun to write your
first concurrent programs and
play around with this stuff.
And you should definitely try
them out and do things to see
how they behave.
But don't overdo it.
These ideas in Go and, for
that matter, the other
languages I mentioned, are not
not replacements for things
like memory barriers to protect
the innards of software.
They're really sort of
high-level building block-like
things that you use to take
simple pieces of and connect
them together into larger
concurrent things.
They're big ideas.
They're really tools for
program construction.
Remember, I said concurrency
is a model for software
construction?
These concurrent tools are
models for software
construction.
But sometimes, you don't
need that much power.
If you need a reference counter,
you could write one
with a channel on a goroutine.
It's fun to do that
as an exercise.
But I didn't show you that,
because I think
that's a silly example.
It's using much too heavyweight
a tool for a very
simple thing.
So Go has these packages in
the sync directory, called
atomic and-- what was the
other one called?
Sync and sync/atomic.
And they contain these low-level
guys for things like
reference counters when
that's all you need.
And sometimes it is
all you need.
So you have to balance the
sort of program structure
you're doing.
Glue together the large things
with these tools I've shown
you, but sometimes if all you
want to do is count the number
of times somebody hits your
page, all you really need is a
reference counter.
So as always, you should use
the right tool for the job.
So in conclusion, goroutines
and channels are the
concurrent features of Go.
And they make it very, very easy
to construct interesting
concurrent software that solves
real-world problems
that include things like having
multiple inputs, having
multiple outputs, independent
execution, timeouts, failures,
replication, robustness.
All those things that are sort
of features of the modern
programming landscape, Go
actually gives you the tools
to manage very, very well.
And it's actually--
even if you're dealing with
boring people, it's actually
kind of fun to work with.
So here's some links for you.
I think that's the last slide.
I'll just leave that one up so
you can look at these during
the question period.
The Go home page, golang.org,
has tons and tons of
resources, videos, the language
spec, package
documentation, of which there's
a phenomenal amount,
lots of second-order documents
like tutorials and blog posts
and stuff like that.
And then at the bottom and
barely readable down at the
bottom here, there's this
tinyurl.com link to my talk at
the Heroku conference earlier
this year, about concurrency
is not parallelism, which also
has some other examples that
are a little richer than some of
the other ones I showed you
today, because today
I was really
concentrating on the basics.
So with that, I'll stop and
maybe take some questions.
[APPLAUSE]
ROB PIKE: Go to the microphones,
please, so that
the people at home
can play along.
AUDIENCE: So one question I
had-- so the only other tool,
I think, that competes with Go
for concurrency support is
Haskell, which I
use regularly.
And Haskell does feature some
speculative parallel operators.
I was wondering if those might
ever appear in Go.
ROB PIKE: Haskell is a
beautiful language.
It's a really lovely language.
But it has a very, very
different model.
And I think, to my mind, the
functional stuff sort of comes
for free with Haskell, but the
whole idea behind the language
is the lazy evaluation
kind of stuff.
And I think it's an excellent
fit for Haskell.
I don't think it's a
good fit for Go.
And in fact, Doug McIlroy took
the concurrent power series
example and rewrote
it in Haskell.
And it's a very beautiful
program that I can't
understand at all.
But it's very beautiful.
So I'm not trying to make
fun of Haskell.
I'm really not, because it
is amazing language.
But I think that the key point
about the way the concurrency
features work in Go is that they
work with the way Go, as
a language, also works.
And you can't just borrow a
feature from another language
and stick it in yours and
expect it to work well.
That art of choosing
what to put in your
language is part of it.
So this is not to say
at all those ideas
aren't really powerful.
I just don't think they're
a good match for Go.
And if it turns out that
I'm wrong, maybe
they should go in.
But offhand, I don't think
they're a good fit.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you comment on
best practices for testing
goroutines?
Because it seems like you're
quasi-integration testing.
Or are there mocks
for goroutines?
Or how would you
go about that?
ROB PIKE: So best--
it's hard to hear you.
So best practices for testing
concurrent code?
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
And for testing goroutines.
ROB PIKE: Best practices.
Write good tests.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
ROB PIKE: Are you worried about
the non-determinism?
AUDIENCE: Well, It seems like,
if you think about goroutines
as external services, you're
thinking about basically
integration testing.
ROB PIKE: Well, one of the
amazing things about--
let me back up here.
It's actually kind of a
non-issue because of the way
the language works.
So let me find the example
I'm looking for.
Where is it?
Actually, I went back
way too far.
I could have used a
much earlier one.
Here we go.
Look.
Look at this guy here,
this example.
The total interface to this
service is a channel.
Nowhere does this function here
know what that channel
has behind it.
It's just this function
in the background
that's doing something.
It could be an arbitrarily
complex computation.
And once you realize that that
channel is, in effect, the
capability to a service, you can
mock this service with a
simple thing.
In fact, this might be a mock
for a service that returns
values at arbitrary intervals.
So I mean, it's a perfectly
good question, but all the
tools I've shown you to do
that are right here.
You don't need--
the whole idea of a channel
is that it hides
what's behind it.
And so that's mocking,
right there.
You've got it.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Because it's a first-class--
ROB PIKE: It's a first-clas
citizen in the language.
AUDIENCE: --that's your mock.
ROB PIKE: Right.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ROB PIKE: Cool.
Sorry.
Let me get to the slide you
really want to look at.
There we go.
OK.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My question is somehow related
because I really like the way
you take concurrency as a
first-classing language.
For instance, in typed language,
you do the static
analysis of the types, runtime
analysis of the types, and
everything works right.
Do you plan on doing something
similar in Go?
Signs in a way that--
OK.
If you do this, you're going
to write to that lock or if
you keep doing this, you're
going to have a lock Or you
are going to have a bottleneck
the way you have arranged all
these patterns.
Do the Go compilers go through
any kind of prettification of
the concurrency properties
of your program?
ROB PIKE: I'm sorry.
I'm having a really hard time
understanding you because the
speakers are pointing
backwards,
and I'm behind them.
You're asking about the static
channel network and how we
typecheck that kind of thing?
AUDIENCE: Go is great for
writing concurrency programs,
but do you plan or do you do
any kind of verification of
that concurrency, either
statically or at runtime?
ROB PIKE: OK.
So you want to know
about static
verification of the thing?
For that kind of thing, I think
independent tools are
the way to go.
There's a thread sanitizer
project that is coming out.
I don't know if it's
actually out yet.
Is it out yet?
Yeah, it is.
It's from Google.
And they have support for
the Go environment.
And so you can embed the
thread-sanitized version of
the world inside your program,
and it will actually look for
data races and stuff like
that, if that matters.
From a communication point of
view, tools like the SPIN
thing that Gerard Holzmann did,
stuff like that I think
is a really good way to model
these kinds of things for
static checking.
And a long time ago, Gerard
did some stuff for us to
statically verify pieces of
the Plan 9 kernel and its
communication and
synchronization stuff using SPIN.
And I've been thinking of
actually approaching him and
asking him to support Go's
primitives, so he can actually
read a Go program and generate a
SPIN model for it and verify
it statically.
And I think that's actually
fairly straightforward to do,
but it hasn't been done.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ROB PIKE: Please speak
carefully and slowly
so I can hear you.
AUDIENCE: So I have
two questions.
I hope it's OK.
You showed us a read from a
time.After channel inside a
select and inside a loop.
Say I wanted to write
time.After.
How would I know from the other
side that the channel
has fallen out of scope so as
to not be locked forever,
waiting for the read.
ROB PIKE: You mean,
how do you know--
so this guy, if the timeout
doesn't fire,
what happens to him?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and what happens
to the code that's in
on the other side.
ROB PIKE: It'll get
garbage-collected.
AUDIENCE: So--
ROB PIKE: So if you want to
know that-- if this is a
richer example, and this is not
time.After but some more
complicated thing, you want to
know that he got your message?
That's this example
right here.
AUDIENCE: No, I actually want
to know, on the other side.
If I'm writing the time.After
function, and I wait my time,
and then write to
the channel--
ROB PIKE: Right.
AUDIENCE: But the write locks
me until it is read--
ROB PIKE: Right.
AUDIENCE: So if it, instead of
being read, it never gets read
and the channel falls out of
scope, will I just be locked
there, and then I will be
garbage-collected completely?
ROB PIKE: Yep.
It's actually--
there's more subtlety
than that, but yeah.
I mean, you shouldn't
be worrying
about it at this level.
That's the short
version of it.
The time.After function uses
some of these ideas, but it's
slightly more sophisticated
than the basic
stuff I've shown you.
If you really care about when
your resource is released,
then you have to write more
sophisticated code than some
of the stuff I've shown you.
There is some stuff in the
Google stuff where there's
blocking going on behind
the scenes that's
also hidden from you.
In the time available, I can't
go through all of the
subtleties of that.
That's probably a subject
for another talk.
AUDIENCE: OK.
But essentially, if I am locked
on that channel that
gets garbage-collected, so no
one is going to unlock me, I
will be garbage-collected,
no problem, right?
ROB PIKE: In many cases, yes.
It depends on the specific
example.
AUDIENCE: Second question is,
how did you do the any number
of stacks that grow
independently?
ROB PIKE: I'm sorry,
I can't hear you.
AUDIENCE: The any number
of stacks that grow
independently.
ROB PIKE: Yep
AUDIENCE: Are you allocating the
stack frames on the heap?
How do you do that?
ROB PIKE: They're allocated and
managed, yes, by the heap.
They have a special allocator.
They're not garbage-collected
in the standard collector,
because we know more
about them.
But they're allocated and
free fairly cheaply.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ROB PIKE: Sorry.
I'm having trouble
hearing you.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
about the select control
structure that you had.
You were saying that if multiple
cases are ready at
the same time, then you
pseudo-randomly choose one,
rather than evaluating
them in order.
Is there a way to write it
so that you could have a
higher-priority case if
you wrote it first?
Or would you just have to
nest them or something?
ROB PIKE: You would nest them.
AUDIENCE: You'd put the default
as another select.
ROB PIKE: Yeah.
One of the many properties of
Go is we tried to take away
things like priorities and
fine-tuning adjustments and
stuff like that.
There's enough power here to do
that kind of stuff, but you
have to write more code, as
opposed to making the API
really complicated.
So you can do prioritized stuff
in select, but yeah.
You basically nest
them to do it.
You put the guys you care
about most first, and if
they're not ready, then you
try the other ones.
AUDIENCE: Gotcha.
OK.
ROB PIKE: This is somewhat
related to the earlier
question but a little
bit more specific.
So is there a way, if you create
a channel, to determine
how many readers or writers
there are for a given channel?
AUDIENCE: Yeah. there's a
built-in function you can use
to see how many values are in a
buffered channel, if it's a
buffered channel.
For a non-buffered channel like
these, there is no way at
the moment to find out
how many readers and
writers there are.
One of the reasons for that
is any such question is
inherently unsafe.
Because if you care how many
readers and writers there are,
then that's because you're going
to do some computation
based on that.
But that computation might be
wrong by the time you end up
doing the computation,
because the number of
values could change.
When you have this kind of thing
it's much more rigorous,
because you know this
communication actually
proceeded, and there's
no doubt about that.
If you say, can I proceed?
OK, I'll get a value.
You don't know that someone else
might have come in and
stolen that value, and you
didn't know about it.
AUDIENCE: Right.
ROB PIKE: So it's actually
sort of an
important point there.
AUDIENCE: The example I was
thinking of is, let's say in
your main method, you
create a channel.
And then you attempt to read
from that channel, but there
are no writers to
that channel.
Or the inverse, you attempt to
write to that channel, but
there are no readers.
ROB PIKE: Right.
AUDIENCE: Do you just
block indefinitely?
Or--
ROB PIKE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Does it
determine that--
OK.
So it doesn't determine--
ROB PIKE: You'll have to-- you
know, if there's multiple
writers, then the first guy to
get there gets the first
value, is how it works.
And it's FIFO semantics.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
ROB PIKE: Yep.
Any other questions?
All right, at the back there's
the usual collection of
goodies to be handed
out carefully.
Please don't mob the
helpful staff.
And thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]